all right one last thing before i set
you loose on question two in your in
your bookmark exercise is there all this
talk about integrating or
differentiating with respect to a
certain variable right and usually it's
x
it leads you to think i should be able
to integrate or differentiate with
respect to any variable i like right and
sometimes doing that is more convenient
so if you have a look at 2a now how do
we determine this area well obviously we
don't need integration to do this area
because it's just a triangle okay but
they pick one of these out so that you
can integrate it and then do it with a
triangle so you can show you're getting
the right answer okay
now without current methods right
which is all to do with x
the way that you might think about it is
well if i integrate with respect to x i
won't get this area right
because you'll get the area bounded by
this curve and
underneath it right it's areas under
curves okay
now
in this case it is but if i gave you a
different less simple function
so
integrating with respect to x okay i
might write this down and you should too
because it's important right uh
integrating with respect to x right it
will give you an area
bounded by the curve
i know my um my function in this case is
not very curvy but you get the idea
by the curve and
the axis that matches the variable okay
so in this case it'd be the x-axis
yeah
now i don't want that area i mean it
could give me the same answer yes but i
want an area that's bounded by the curve
and the y-axis so how would i do it you
differentiate
the integrand the integral integral
okay now
this is this is a um a definite integral
because it's actually an area right so i
need to pick some upper and lower bounds
but
but
if i'm
integrating not with respect to x but
with respect to y then my boundaries
also ought to be
in y right so this will get a little
more um confusing when we look at
integrating and substitution okay but
for now you can see look this is zero at
the origin right so instead of going
from zero to over here which i guess
that would be ten
right based on this function um i don't
want to do with respect to x i want to
do with respect to y so those are the
bounds i'm going to pick not so five
okay now conveniently this is kind of
their subtle hint right they've given
you the function with x as the subject
right rather than giving it to you as y
equals x or two okay so therefore we
actually don't need to do any work here
we just have to say well look the part
that i'm interested in is that one the
2y right x is already the subject so
i'll take 2y and i'll integrate with
respect to y that will give me an area
bounded by the curve and the y axis okay
so
now that i've set it up which is kind of
actually the hard part okay now i can
actually go and carry out the
integration right
um
the premium function of 2y is
y squared y squared y squared it's easy
at these early stages to get integration
and differentiation confused with each
other okay
then i want my bounds so 0 5
now by the way i know you can evaluate
this straight away but you mustn't miss
out the fact that now i've got to do
f of b minus f of a don't miss both of
them because that means you don't
understand what the um what this
notation actually means what an integral
is okay so even though it's zero
i'm going to put the evaluation of the
lower bound in there okay so that's 25.
now usually i would have started off by
saying that's a for area okay just like
in differentiation this whole process
has nothing to do with units right so if
you were like pouring water in and it
was like meals per
second or minute or something like that
all of those units should come after now
will you get dr marks if you just say
this
probably not
plenty of people do it and we just don't
have the whole box to throw around but
what's is you know is it correct no no
it's not like units don't just pop up
and disappear out of you know um because
you want them to so really you want to
say at the end here the area is
25 units
squared
question three
read it with me it says find the area of
right and then it gives you these shapes
now area tell me can area be negative no
unless it falls in on itself
now the question of area area is meant
to be something we can measure right so
area should be positive only now you go
go and evaluate those when you get to
question three and surprise surprise
you'll find that it's negative why
because underneath the axis right now
just do a thought experiment with me
if you were to integrate something like
say this function okay and assuming
there was some symmetry to it okay
what if we went from zero to
whatever four on y equals x minus two
that's what it looks like to me okay
what would you expect the integral the
definite integral
of this
uh of these bounds zero four what would
you expect it to give you
the expected gives you right because
these will exactly cancel out now
that's the definite integral so the
integral of from 0 to 4 of x minus 2 dx
sure enough should be 0. okay but is
that the area
no it's not right the area is whatever
one of the triangles is and double it
okay so you need to pay very very close
attention to what the question actually
asks you okay
in the exercise you've got at the moment
anyway they're all underneath so it
would almost be fine to just slap
absolute value signs on there okay but
later on when you've got these mixtures
of areas you've got to be a little more
cautious but we'll deal with examples of
that later okay
make sense